el gobierno egipcio ha visto la Cumbre
del clima como una oportunidad de oro
para proyectar una imagen favorable del
país codearse con los líderes del mundo
y formar parte como actor principal de
la resolución o potencial resolución de
uno de los principales retos a los que
se enfrenta el mundo en este momento
pero las cosas no están saliendo
exactamente como esperaban y de ello se
está encargando a la azafatada un
bloguero y activista egipcio que ha
pasado la mayor parte de los pasados 8
años en prisión en las cárceles egipcias
hoy ha estado hablando como delegada en
esa Cumbre del clima en charleseft su
hermana menor que también conoce desde
dentro las cárceles egipcias ha dicho
que su hermano se encuentra en un
precario estado de salud y que está
destinado a morir en prisión lleva
varios meses en huelga de hambre y desde
el domingo coincidiendo con el inicio de
la Cumbre del clima a la ha dejado
también de beber agua es solamente uno
de los más de 60.000 prisioneros
políticos que están en las cárceles
egipcias de un abogado de Derechos
Humanos hace unos años que a la
representa todo lo que el régimen
egipcio no es la democracia la dignidad
la libertad por eso le mantiene en
prisión su hermana ha pedido hoy su
libertad y ha reiterado que no hay
resolución de la crisis climática si no
se respetan los Derechos Humanos